foreign
[Music]
guys this week it's time for another
video request and the question I got is
this Daniel how to be more successful in
life a lot of people ask this question I
used to ask this myself when I was
younger until I realized it depends on
what you understand about success how do
you view success ask yourself this
question are you content with the way
you are right now or do you want to be
better do you want to improve yourself
to be the best man that you can be
some of you might say well Daniel when I
look at the lives of other people
when I compare myself to them I can't be
that successful
that's problem number one stop comparing
yourself to other people why do you do
that
stop doubting yourself first understand
you have no idea how hard someone else
has worked to achieve their success
and what sacrifices they made to achieve
it and second our lives are all
different and you cannot compare it your
success will look different from someone
else's success
so how do you measure success
when you look at where you are today
compared to where you started
when we look about jobs my career I when
I was 16 years old that was the first
time that I started to work I was a
waiter at a restaurant in South Africa
called wimpy
I grew up very poor and I worked hard
for everything that I have today when I
was 16 up until 18 when I finished high
school I left with my two brothers after
school I got a job in England I stayed
with a few other South Africans working
for the same sales company and while
they slept at night I stayed up studying
learning everything I could about the
company and their competitors after
England I got the Breakthrough in
modeling I jimmed and worked out really
hard and I started to travel the world
while studying online for my two degrees
one in Psychology and the other in
theology then I also started to work on
my first YouTube channel at night while
other guys went out partying I was
teaching myself how to film edit upload
and rank videos
now if we fast forward a lot of hard
work and sacrifices fast forward here I
am today two YouTube channels with a
combined following of over 1.5 million
subscribers and in my free time I'm now
working to get a game company off the
ground and this is not about me this is
all about you
all of my work is not for me it's for
you because that is what gives me the
greatest joy
after I lost my brothers I realized man
I need to First Look to God living the
light accept him as my Lord and Savior
and be a good man and do the best that I
can do while I still have breath in my
lungs and bring value to other people
so everything that I do I'm trying my
best to bring value to you guys to
change lives and that to me means
success
and I have still so much more to learn I
have a lot more room to grow and improve
there's a quote that says success is no
accident it is hard work perseverance
learning studying sacrifice and most of
all love of what you are doing or
learning to do
now I don't just want to talk about my
career or what I do so you think oh
that's success no it's a lot more than
that it's me myself that changed over
the years and the biggest change oh the
biggest Improvement was when I became a
reborn Christian
when I was in my early 20s when my
second brother died that changed
everything for me and since that day I
seeked truth
I wanted to live in it grow in it I
wanted to be a better man and I never
stopped since that day and now when I
look back
I can see that I'm successful in that as
well but I still have much much much
more to learn
foreign
so the first thing you need to do to be
successful is to change your mind to
change your attitude and your actions
you need to understand this because it's
like a flat tire if you don't change
you're not going to go anywhere
and if you change your attitude you will
realize that the world around you is
also changing Eleanor Roosevelt said you
can often change your circumstances by
changing your attitude if you always
have a negative attitude everything you
see Everything You Touch everything you
do will always be negative you need to
change the way you look at things the
way you think you need to take your
thoughts captive every one of them
control them and to do that you need to
do five things one write down your goals
two dedicate yourself to achieving those
goals three discipline yourself in Mind
Body
and spirit
four change your habits by changing your
daily routine five
be consistent
now always remember one thing the devil
will come and bring negativity and doubt
you need to identify those thoughts and
push them out as soon as you get them
into your mind don't just go along with
them you cannot always decide what
thoughts come into your head but you can
choose which thought you will go with
think about a little bit more
stop them because if you don't stop them
they will stop you from achieving your
goals and negative thoughts steal so
much time
that you could have used to work for
your goals
the second thing you need to do is to
make an active decision to always have a
good work ethic
there are a lot of people in this world
that are lazy
and they will never achieve their goals
why because the words lazy and
successful never goes together
for lazy people it's always easier to
sleep late in the morning press that
snooze button
it's always easier to watch 10 episodes
on Netflix or play 5 hours of games
instead of watching one quick video on
learning a new skill and improving
yourself
some people say well I don't have the
talents to be successful
don't lie to yourself
there are a lot of courses out there
that you can just go and learn improve
yourself I mean YouTube it's free that's
where I learned how to edit videos
and listen carefully
let this truth sink in work ethic
doesn't require any Talent at all but it
sets successful people apart from those
who fail
stop being lazy stop procrastinating and
when you do things do more
you know those times when you feel like
man I'm so tired I can't do anymore
that's exactly the moment when you need
to push yourself even harder because
that is the moment you realize wow I can
actually do more than I think I can
do more than just help someone care for
them to more than just talk show it with
your actions and always remember it
doesn't matter what other people are
doing it matters what you are doing
build strong relationships
you're young some of you and you might
think man I can get where I want to be
just by myself I don't need anyone's
help
the truth is you probably won't get
there without the support of other
people not only that you will need the
connections to get where you want to be
a lot faster you know sometimes the
young people they think man older people
they don't know anything you can learn a
lot from them because they have a lot
more experience in life than you do
have you ever wondered older people why
do they know so many people what do they
have so many connections because when
they need a good lawyer or a good
plumber or a good doctor or a good
mechanic they know exactly who to call
you won't be able to do everything in
life you can't do all professions but
you can make friends with people from
different professions so that when you
need their help they are there to help
you and you are there the moment that
they need help as well
Anthony D'Angelo said treasure your
relationships not your possessions
this comes down to trust and loyalty you
know loyalty is one of the most precious
things that you can find in this world
when it comes to relationships everybody
wants it
but it's so hard to find because
you cannot get loyalty from someone if
you don't give them honesty
so be a man of your word
only if you're a man of your word then
you will earn people's trust
and then loyalty kindness some of you
did not expect me to say this well
Daniel why do I need to be kind to be
successful in life well let me explain
let me explain it this way I actually
don't really care much about what
someone has achieved in their life what
success they achieved
but show me what they do with that
success show me how they treat other
people
and that will tell me exactly what kind
of person they are
Danny Thomas said success in life has
nothing to do with what you gain in Life
or accomplish for yourself
it's what you do for others
success without kindness without caring
about other people is not success
it is a waste of time
always ask yourself
what will people say about you when you
die
use time effectively all of us we get
the same time 24 hours each day seven
days a week what do you do with that
time now that that's on you you can
waste it on things that do not improve
you your future or the lives of other
people or you can use it to do exactly
that
first always be on time never be late
for appointments
this is one of those kind of things that
you need to learn as a young man as a
young boy you know always be on time
it's exactly the same as always make
your bed because if you don't make your
bed you're a lazy person you don't have
self-discipline so when it comes to time
be on time I love Japanese people
because they are always on time and it
shows professionalism
time is precious time is life and if
your time runs out so does your life
think about this if you're running late
you think why I'm just running late 10
minutes 15 minutes there's no big
problem but you're actually stealing 20
minutes from someone else's life
because you cause them to wait for you
for 20 minutes
second schedule your priorities do that
every day focus on it to do those things
that will get you closer to your goals
and when you achieve a goal each goal is
slowly getting you closer to your dream
it needs to become a daily routine so
that it will change your habits and that
means if it is a routine then you'll be
able to be consistent
be prepared if you don't plan ahead
you're planning to fail
a lot of people are very optimistic and
they are very positive when they start
something
but being optimistic and being positive
will not get you anywhere if you don't
plan and please hear me today a lot of
people experience problems
just because they were not prepared
people spend a lot of time and effort to
try and fix their problems in this world
but many do not realize that they can
prevent most of the problems they
experience if they are just prepared
you know there's a lot of people in
school and they say man I'm not going to
use this one day in life or this is what
I need to learn here from school I'm not
gonna use this it might be true but what
school does teach you is that you need
to work hard and not be lazy do things
that you sometimes do not like because
that is what it needs to be successful
sometimes you need to do things even
when you don't feel like at end
you always need to do research and
educate yourself and that is what school
is great at school teaches you how to
teach yourself and you need to get into
the habit of doing research not being
lazy but to learn because in life you
always need to do research to know your
options before you make a decision and
always have a backup plan for a backup
plan
adapt you know even if you do everything
that I've already talked about perfectly
you still need to adapt because man
there's life this life will throw you
not just one or two but a few curveballs
you need to expect the unexpected
because unexpected things that you
cannot control will happen your Wi-Fi
will go down in South Africa you can
expect power failure due to Cable theft
your car can break down or they might
steal your car your roof might be
leaking suddenly or your friend might
let you down or even worse someone close
to you might die all of the things that
I've just mentioned happen to me
you need to expect the unexpected and
when it does happen you need to adapt
and the faster you do it the better it
will be because the longer you sit and
complain about it
the longer you'll stay in it and sitting
in it wishing it was different is not
going to change reality
but you can you can do something about
it John Wooden said if we fail to adapt
we fail to move forward you only have
two options when you encounter obstacles
you can either just give up or you can
adapt and move on
never give up because you will fail many
times in this life over and over and
over again
but that is what is needed to change you
to make you stronger and then when you
do achieve success it'll be so much more
sweeter you'll appreciate it so much
more
see as Lewis said failures and repeated
failures are finger posts on the road to
achievement one fails forward towards
success
and before you do anything at all make
sure that you have the right dreams the
right goals in the first place because
if you don't you'll waste a lot of time
I prayed a long time before God pointed
me to the right direction in my middle
20s that's the first time that God
really spoke to me I prayed and prayed
and prayed breakthrough prayer until he
answered me three different ways if you
want to know more about my life
then watch this video here my testimony
from my other channel and I'll see you
there
and always remember life is short so
don't waste yours cheers guys